(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Estamos chegando aqui ao final do nosso curso,
essa é a última aula do nosso curso
e eu queria conversar um pouco com vocês
sobre consultoria para leilão.
Como eu já falei algumas vezes antes do
curso e durante o curso, uma consultoria especializada
em leilão de imóveis tende a cobrar entre
7% e 10% do valor de
cada arrematação para fazer aquele trabalho de procurar
o imóvel, analisar a documentação, realizar o lance
e depois cuidar da desocupação daquele imóvel.
Você agora que chegou ao final do curso
e que pode colocar na prática tudo o
que você aprendeu, também pode lucrar com uma
consultoria de imóvel, mesmo que você não seja
advogado.
Existem inúmeras consultorias de leilão judicial que quem
presta consultoria não é advogado e sim a
pessoa que tem o conhecimento prático e sabe
de tudo aquilo que tem que ser feito
para realizar uma arrematação segura e esse pode
ser o seu caso caso você não seja
um advogado e também caso você seja um
advogado.
Hoje em dia as pessoas não ficam tão
reescritas a títulos, ah, leilão judicial acontece dentro
de um processo, então eu preciso de um
advogado para me auxiliar nesse leilão judicial.
As pessoas querem um profissional que tenha capacidade,
que tenha prática e que tenha o conhecimento
pleno daquilo que está fazendo.
Então você pode ser esse profissional colocando tudo
em prática, isso vale ainda mais quando a
gente fala em investimento, quando a gente mexe
com dinheiro, a pessoa não quer entregar o
dinheiro dela para quem não tem nenhum conhecimento
prático daquilo, para quem não exerce aquilo, ela
quer entregar o dinheiro dela em quem ela
possa confiar, em alguém que ela sabe que
vive daquilo ali, que tem a prática daquilo
ali, que sabe fazer aquilo ali, então essa
é a forma que você pode lucrar prestando
consultoria independente da sua profissão, pode ser que
você num primeiro momento faça isso uma renda
extra e depois pode ser que efetivamente você
torne isso aí a sua profissão e agora
pode ser que você que não é advogado
se pergunte, ah, mas e se eu precisar
de um advogado para realizar a desocupação de
um imóvel?
Então vamos lá, vamos ao exemplo prático, você
está auxiliando alguém numa arrematação de 200 mil
reais e para isso você cobrou 7%
do valor da arrematação, então você vai ganhar
como remuneração pelo seu trabalho 14 mil reais,
que é 7% de 200 mil e
aí pode ser que você não seja advogado
e que nesse leilão específico você vai precisar
de um advogado para fazer uma emissão na
posse porque você não conseguiu um acordo para
desocupação voluntária daquele imóvel e aí você pode
procurar um advogado ou você já pode ter
um advogado parceiro que sempre receba esses seus
processos e faça da forma mais rápida possível,
que fique estipulado ali que você vai pagar
4 mil reais para aquele advogado, você cobrou
14 para prestar aquela consultoria, se você pagar
4 para um advogado você ainda tem assim
um lucro de 10 mil reais exclusivamente pelo
seu trabalho intelectual, pela análise que você vai
fazer daquele processo, isso é um lucro muito
expressivo, então pode ser perfeitamente possível para qualquer
profissional que comece a realizar esse tipo de
consultoria e se você precisar de um advogado,
caso você não seja um, você pode arrumar
um advogado parceiro para realizar esse procedimento com
você, não necessariamente um sócio seu não, você
arruma um advogado que cobre um preço que
você ache ok para realizar um serviço e
toda vez que você tiver que recorrer a
um, você vai direto naquele, você não precisa
ficar procurando algum advogado no mercado, você já
deixaria um preço pré-estabelecido para aquele serviço
que ainda assim você consiga lucrar bastante com
a consultoria que você vai prestar, você também
num primeiro momento, se for a sua opção,
você pode começar com um serviço mais simples,
tem muita gente que sabe o que precisa
ser feito para arrematar, sabe o que tem
que analisar, chegou ali, analisou a documentação, olhou
e falou realmente esse apartamento aqui é um
bom apartamento para arrematar, mas ainda assim fique
inseguro, que é ouvir uma segunda opinião somente
sobre a análise daquela documentação, você não vai
precisar fazer uma pesquisa maior de campo, você
só vai analisar edital, matrícula e falar para
a pessoa, não, realmente esse apartamento aqui é
um bom apartamento, ou realmente essa casa aqui
está valendo a pena, e aí você vai
ser só a segunda voz dessa pessoa, para
isso você pode cobrar um pouco mais barato,
isso vai ficar a seu critério, porque você
não vai precisar prestar aquela consultoria completa, você
vai ser só uma voz de tranquilidade para
algum tipo de investidor, e existe bastante gente
que também procura esse serviço, que já sabe
que tem que ser feito, mas ainda assim
queria só uma opiniãozinha para confirmar se realmente
aquilo ali é válido ou não.
Qual é a melhor forma então de você
atrair pessoas que possam estar interessadas na consultoria
que você vai prestar?
A melhor forma é você demonstrar conhecimento, então
pode ser que num primeiro momento você conheça
pessoas que façam investimentos de outros tipos, como
bolsa, tesouro direto, estejam procurando alguma forma para
diversificar seus documentos, monte um dossiê sobre imóvel
específico, coloque nesse dossiê o valor que o
imóvel está indo a leilão, o valor de
mercado daquele imóvel, se existe possibilidade de sobrar
dívida, qual é o condomínio mensal daquele imóvel,
qual é o IPTU mensal daquele imóvel, o
estado de conservação daquele imóvel, qual seria o
lucro líquido que a pessoa pode esperar daquele
imóvel, após um ano entre arrematação e venda,
com todos os pagamentos de todos os custos,
corretor, imposto de renda sobre o lucro, eventual
reforma e TBI, registro, basicamente é apresentar os
cálculos que a calculadora aqui do curso faz
para você, apresente isso para essas pessoas que
você conhece, que já investem e falam, você
conhece a possibilidade de investir em imóvel, arrematando
esse imóvel por 40, 50% do valor
de mercado através de leilão, muita gente nunca
ouviu falar de leilão ou já ouviu falar,
mas está cheio daquelas crenças que a gente
conversou aqui no começo do curso, de que
o arrematante está sempre causando mal para alguém,
de que é muito difícil desocupar um imóvel,
apresente todos esses pontos de vista para essas
pessoas que você possa conhecer, que realizem outros
tipos de investimento, tente trazer essa pessoa para
um investimento em leilão de imóvel, fale que
você presta consultoria, que você faz essa consultoria
do começo ao fim, que você vai desde
encontrar um imóvel até entregar a chave daquele
imóvel na mão do arrematante, imóvel desocupado para
ele vender da forma que ele preferir, já
apresente todos os custos que apesar de você
entregar aquele imóvel desocupado, que você vai encerrar
o seu serviço na fase de desocupação, após
a desocupação ser cumprida, mas que o que
ele gastar com o corretor de imóvel você
já calculou e o lucro dele ainda vai
ser de tantos por cento ao final de
um ano, faça esse trabalho completo, apresente, essa
é uma forma muito eficaz de você conseguir
prestar uma consultoria alguém ou até mesmo de
você arrematar usando seu capital intelectual, você pode
também chegar num grupo e propor a seguinte
divisão, olha cada um vai ficar com 25
por cento de um imóvel, mas eu vou
entrar com o meu capital intelectual e você
entra com dinheiro e no final a gente
racha o valor daquele lucro, tem muita gente
que apesar do conhecimento bater a porta, de
ter a oportunidade de aprender, a pessoa não
quer aprender, a pessoa quer pagar para que
alguém faça, ela quer ter um rendimento mais
facilitado, ela não quer ter nenhum trabalho, ela
não quer comparecer a um cartório para registrar
imóvel, ela quer simplesmente pagar e quer que
alguém resolva para ela, e aí pode ser
uma boa alternativa para você também, de além
de prestar consultoria, também propor algo desse tipo,
eu entro com o meu conhecimento intelectual e
você entra com o capital necessário para arrematar
aquele imóvel, perfeitamente válido também, registre tudo em
um contrato, independente se for uma consultoria ou
se for esse tipo de divisão que você
vai fazer especificamente do imóvel, deixe tudo bem
combinado para que depois alguém não possa levantar
alguma dúvida de que deveria ter sido feito
mais alguma coisa que não foi feito, deixe
tudo expresso no contrato, que aquilo vai trazer
segurança para todo mundo, também existe outra opção
de você utilizar as redes sociais, existe muita
gente que busca em redes sociais outras formas
de investimento, a mais utilizada hoje em dia
talvez seja o Instagram, então é possível que
você monte um perfil no Instagram para começar
a divulgar os procedimentos de consultoria que você
vai prestar, e aí é necessário que você
use uma abordagem talvez um pouco mais agressiva,
não deixe para pesquisar o imóvel só quando
alguém aparecer e falar olha eu tenho 200
mil e eu queria um imóvel de 200
mil, faça essa análise prévia, separe ali um
tempo do seu dia e analise algum leilão
que vai acontecer, que esteja com uma boa
margem de desconto e faça uma chamada atraente,
esse imóvel de 600 mil você pode comprar
por 300 mil no dia tal, imóvel localizado
em tal lugar, e aí peça para pessoa
entrar em contato com você e aí você
explica como é que você trabalha com a
sua consultoria, faça essa pegada um pouco mais
agressiva de já mostrar o que a pessoa
quer ver, não ficar só falando de leilão
de forma genérica sem mostrar na prática qual
o resultado que ela poderia ter, já presente
esse resultado?
Agora no começo, logo após acabar o curso,
pode ser que você demore um pouco mais
para fazer as análises necessárias em cada tipo
de leilão, num leilão escrito-judicial, num leilão
judicial, mas isso com o passar do tempo
vai ficando cada vez mais rápido, vai ficando
cada vez mais automático, você já baixa na
matrícula, você já sabe o que você tem
que esperar, você não precisa recorrer a nenhum
outro lugar, você já vai saber o que
significa aqueles termos de cara, isso tudo com
estudo contínuo, assim como acontece com qualquer matéria,
quando a gente estuda qualquer matéria de forma
contínua, um estudo duradouro, as coisas vão ficando
sempre muito mais fáceis, então pode ser agora
que nessa última aula talvez você esteja na
dúvida o que significa um leilão de direitos,
o que significa na prática ter um criador
hipotecário, pode ser que nesse primeiro momento você
tenha que voltar várias vezes em cada aula
e reassistir para poder consolidar o entendimento dentro
da sua mente, mas isso vai ficando muito
mais fácil com o passar do tempo, se
você fizer um estudo contínuo, então a análise
de um leilão, ela fica cada vez mais
rápida, pode ser que no primeiro momento você
demore 4 horas para analisar um leilão, e
depois em um patamar mais avançado, você em
uma hora veja tudo que é necessário, então
você não vai perder muito tempo fazendo essa
abordagem mais agressiva, fazendo essa análise, e lembre
que esse seu perder tempo que você vai
dispor antes de receber algo de alguém, é
para atrair pessoas, quando você receber o valor,
muitas vezes você já recebeu por um procedimento
que você já analisou, vamos supor, você botou
lá um imóvel de 600 que está indo
a 300, você quando botou lá, você já
fez toda a verificação, não vai botar um
imóvel que você não fez a verificação para
correr o risco de alguém falar, eu quero
esse imóvel específico, e depois que analisar, você
falar, esse imóvel aqui não é um bom
imóvel para arrematar, vai dar problema com isso,
vai sobrar dívida daquilo, então coloque um imóvel
lá que você já realizou a verificação, se
por ventura alguém aparecer interessado naquele imóvel, você
não vai ter o trabalho de novo, você
tem que ter confiança do que aquilo que
você fez no primeiro momento para você poder
anunciar, está correto, então no máximo você vai
revisar se realmente você não pulou nenhum ponto,
mas você vai ser remunerado por um trabalho
que você já fez, então utiliza bastante redes
sociais, mostre que você tem conhecimento sobre aquela
área, fale que você tem uma equipe, mesmo
que você não tenha um escritório, que fisicamente
um advogado fique ali 24 horas por dia
com você, você vai ter uma equipe porque
você se precisar de um trabalho de advogado,
você vai ter em quem você recorrer, você
vai ter procurado previamente quem é um bom
profissional para te ajudar naquela ação de emissão
na posse que pode ser que você precise
realizar em um leilão prejudicial, por exemplo, ou
se foi um leilão judicial que aquele advogado
especificamente vai peticionar naquele processo requerendo a carta
de arrematação, o mandado de emissão na posse,
então fale que você tem todo o suporte
necessário para garantir segurança aquela pessoa e sempre
faça contrato, é muito importante que você faça
um contrato para depois você não ter nenhum
tipo de problema, seja que depois a pessoa
quer barganhar o preço inicialmente acordado ou seja
porque a pessoa vai cobrar alguma coisa que
não estava acordado no que você pretendia prestar
de consultoria, então deixe tudo bem documentado para
que você não possa ter nenhuma surpresa no
futuro e para que você possa gerar lucro
também prestando consultoria, essa é uma vantagem que
aprender uma área de conhecimento que poucos têm
e leilão é um conhecimento que poucos têm,
pode te proporcionar que você ganhe dinheiro em
duas frentes, seja fazendo sua própria arrematação ou
seja prestando consultoria para outras pessoas.